do you think
uh in uh aerospace
arena in the next five ten years do you
think we're gonna put a human on mars
like what do you think is the
interesting
uh no i do in fact i i made a bet with
someone with a group of people kind of
this about whether boots on mars by 2030
and this was kind of a fun you know a
fun story because i was at an intel
sponsored event and we had a bunch of
just world-class brilliant people and we
were talking about computing stuff but
the after dinner conversation was like
what are some other things how they
gonna go in the future and one of the
ones tossed up on the whiteboard was
like boots on mars by 2030
and most of the people in the room
thought yes you know they thought that
like spacex is kicking ass we've got all
this possible stuff i seems likely that
it's going to go that way and i said no
i think less than 50 chance that it's
going to make it there
and people you know we're kind of like
oh you know why the pessimism or
whatever and of course i'm an optimist
at almost everything but for me to be
the the one kind of outlier saying no i
don't think so um then i started saying
some of the things i said well let's be
concrete about it let's i bet ten
thousand dollars that it's not going to
happen
and this was this was really a startling
thing to see that i again room full of
brilliant people but as soon as like
money came on the line and they were
like do i want to put 10 000. i was not
the richest person in the room uh there
are people much better off than i was
there's a spectrum but i am
you know as soon as they started think
it's like oh i could lose money by by
keeping uh keeping my position right now
and
all these engineers they engaged their
brain they started thinking it's like
okay launch windows uh launch delays
like how many times would it take to get
this right what historical precedence do
we have and i and then it mostly came
down to it's like well what about in
transit by 2030 and then i you know what
about i you know different things or
would you hand would you go for 2032 but
uh one of the people did go ahead and
was optimistic enough to make a bet with
me so i have a ten thousand dollar bet
that by 2030 i think it's going to
happen shortly thereafter i think there
will probably be infrastructure on mars
by 2030 but i don't think that we'll
have humans on mars on 23rd i think it's
possible but i think it's less than a 50
chance so i felt safe making that bet
well i think you had an interesting
point uh correct me if i'm wrong that's
a dark one that's um
that should perhaps help people
appreciate elon musk
which is
in this particular effort
elon is a critical
is critical to success spacex seems to
be
uh critical to 20 you know
humans on mars by 2030 or thereabouts so
if something happens to eulon
then all of this
collapses
you